hey how close were you because i
remember when you jumped on the super
high remix yeah
it i think was human currency was on the
right hooks and i remember
i don't i can't even listen to the
normal version of that record because
that remix is so classic but i remember
there was like rumblings of you possibly
joining mmg at the time like was there
ever like oh did that ever get close to
the finish line rick ross is my man bro
and he's another one shout out to
mcqueen shout out bella claire bamboo
shout out to brett
um he's another one who's like snoop
who's like never stopped throwing me
alley-oops or just putting you know me
in the game and just doing things to
help me out and he'll reach out
personally or tell people like yo [ __ ]
with wiz and he's so cool man like i
love that dude so the story of how that
went down is um
i was i think i did the mixtape monday
on uh on mtv you remember that [ __ ]
remember that [ __ ] yeah
yeah like that was a big deal so i did
cushion orange juice
and i was like i gotta be on [ __ ]
mixtape monday
and they were like you could do it but
we're not sending nobody to film you i
was like [ __ ] y'all i got my own film
crew right so i feel my own [ __ ] like i
film my own intro i film
my interviews i film like my little
video parts in the studio and [ __ ] like
that and they they aired it and he seen
that [ __ ] he was like this [ __ ] is hard
so he called me personally uh he he
hit me up through spiff spiff was uh
tv yeah and uh and sam sneaked out dj jj
yeah yeah dj sam sneak
he hit excuse me he hit me up through
them called me personally was like yo i
[ __ ] with you heavy fly down to atlanta
come to my crib let's just chill record
some songs or whatever i'm like hell
yeah [ __ ] you're rick ross right this
is like peak mmg shit's going crazy
after big meech and all that yeah i'm
like oh hell yeah
so i went down there
he had a pile of wheaties like yo roll
up he took me sneaker shopping he told
me to go get some food he took me to go
get some tattoos we recorded the verses
uh separately like i did my verse in
pittsburgh and spitta did his verse uh
in new orleans because that's what he
was like yo i gotta tap in with both of
y'all like y'all smoking y'all doing
this so we did our verses and then we
flew down there and we shot the video
like that day
spit a left but i stayed another day and
just chilled and then by the time i got
home he called me again and was like yo
i want to sign you this that other thing
and i'm like
bruv
i just started my own label right taylor
gang just started just started i was
like a lot of people don't know like i
got out of a deal at warner but these
[ __ ] are trying to double back and
sign me again and i'm about to get a
hell of a lot more money so after you
left warner the first time yeah they try
to bring you back well the same people
were at atlantic at the time why no like
yeah i mean it was the same
[ __ ] okay okay so the same team
who was at warner ended up over at
atlantic and that's how you ended up at
atlanta that's not how i ended up there
but they ended up having to deal with me
again because i had an anr who was crazy
about me and he brought me to atlantic
and they were like
bro we just had that kid where he was
over there and he was like nah but he's
like he's that dude blah blah blah he's
gonna do this and they're like so
you mean to tell us we gotta sign the
same [ __ ] twice and give him
more money the second time so yeah i
took the money and i had to tell rick
ross like
we're keeping it on the low because like
i didn't want to tell people i was
signing another deal like you know what
i mean like it just wasn't my thing i
didn't want people to take away from the
fact that i was doing all of that [ __ ]
myself yeah making my own youtubes going
on tour doing all my own merch i didn't
want nobody stepping in and taking no
credit or any of that so
they didn't come into the picture
by people until like black and yellow
and [ __ ] but we had already been you
know what i mean talking so that's what
i had to tell rose was like you know i'm
talking to atlantic i'm finna make this
happen but we could always be family we
could always be cool that's big man yeah
man it was good and that's always been a
big homie man he showed me so much love
yo and he still does